[Music]
thank you everyone for joining our
Google Cloud next 2022 section on how AI
infrastructure on gcp helps teams
accelerate ml development with optimized
performance and cost
my name is Mikhail kreska an outbound
product manager on vertex AI Google
Cloud's AI platform I'm excited to have
three other guests with me here today we
have Kai from Uber who's a senior
product manager on Uber's ml platform
Michelangelo and Joanna and Sid from
coheer ml Engineers building tools to
make natural language AI capabilities
accessible to all Developers
we'll start with a quick intro on why AI
infrastructure is important walk through
AI infrastructure services and solutions
available on gcp here customer stories
about leveraging AI infrastructure on
gcp and then wrap up with a quick
summary
so let's start with why is AI
infrastructure imported and the best way
to start really answering this question
is to give you a sneak peek into our
customer stories about how they're using
AI infra to accelerate development and
deployment
cohere is leveraging tpus on gcp to
innovate faster and iterate faster on
large language models Uber has
integrated vertex ai's tabnet and automl
services into their platform to allow
different teams to leverage these new
algorithms
Credit Karma is leveraging vertex ai's
feature store to manage embeddings that
feed into their content engagement and
offer conversions engine and finally
Arbor biotech is leveraging Alpha fold
running on vertex AI to help their
scientists predict structures of protein
sequences in hours instead of months
these examples and many more cannot be
done on general purpose infrastructure
this requires robust ai purpose-built ai
infrastructure
in addition to these specific examples
there is a broader Trend across data and
AI data is getting bigger it's getting
multi-format AI models are getting
larger and more developers are adopting
Frameworks like Pi torch tensorflow the
Transformers library and Jax making AI
research and development more accessible
so infrastructure really needs to keep
up to make AI models performant and cost
effective and having access to strong AI
infrastructure is becoming a competitive
advantage to getting the most value from
AI
and this is also exemplified by these
two quotes from IDC and Forester IDC
shares that the lack of purpose-built AI
infrastructure is now becoming one of
the leading causes of AI infrastructure
failing and Forester shares that AI
infrastructure is really crucial to keep
AI teams productive to keep them
experimenting developing and deploying
rather than just waiting around for
large AI tasks to complete
so now let's move into what does AI
infrastructure on Google cloud look like
and we have three pillars when thinking
about this one flexible and scalable
Hardware to support diverse ml workloads
two manage infrastructure to allow
practitioners to focus on experimenting
and deploying models and this is offered
through vertex AI a fully managed data
science ml Ops platform and number three
really easily access state-of-the-art AI
with optimized infrastructure and
software paired together we're really
looking to bridge the gap between
research and applied AI what we call
research to ready so with a focus of AI
infrastructure as part of an AI strategy
the performance and cost benefits can be
quite staggering along the bottom we see
some great results where some workloads
get up to 6X cost reduction by
optimizing on the right hardware and
we've seen some teams go from ideation
to experimentation to production in
weeks rather than months or quarters
with many teams sharing stories of 80
Improvement and overall velocity across
the ml life cycle so now let's dig into
some of the specific services
on the hardware side we're excited to
welcome two new AI accelerators onto gcp
first the Nvidia A2 Ultra GPU VM
instance this machine has twice the GPU
Ram of the previous A2 Mega machine
providing 80 gigabytes of GPU memory
this provides big performance gains in
throughput as well as latency for use
cases like deep learning recommendations
and computer vision models as well as
large language models
second we're excited to welcome the
newest generation of the tensor
Processing Unit or the TPU this is
infrastructure designed by Google
specifically for machine learning with
support for pi torch Jacks and
tensorflow the fourth generation of tpus
scale to a super pod made up of over 4
000 chips and each chip has big
improvements in flops and flops per
dollar versus the previous Third
Generation in addition to Pure
horsepower the data center hosting the
tpus is operating at 90 carbon free
energy with a big focus on
sustainability
so now let's move on to some of the more
machine learning specific tasks and
large-scale training is really one of
the first ml tasks that requires
purpose-built AI infrastructure vertex
AI provides a fully managed training
service that eliminates the need to
provision and manage clusters users can
submit and forget jobs with the python
SDK get out of the box queue management
access to on-demand accelerators and
built-in hyper parameter tuning moving
on to the middle vertex also provides a
new distributed training capability that
works with existing Frameworks like
horavod or tensorflow's mirror strategy
or Pi towards distributed business
reduction server architecture provides a
new way that minimizes latency and data
transfer benchmarks for language models
have shown up to 30 to 40 percent
reduction in training time and cost
and finally we know many times data
feeding into these accelerators can
often be the bottleneck so we're
launching first class support for cloud
storage and NFS file store as part of
vertex to be easily able to mount these
into your on-demand training jobs for
cloud storage specifically this allows
you to use cloud storage's new auto
class capability that automatically
moves data to lower and colder storage
classes based on access time resulting
in automated cost savings
next we move into the serving layer with
vertex's managed prediction Service
First this is a fully managed API
endpoint service this allows users to
deploy their models into Auto scaling
endpoints with a wide selection of CPUs
and gpus with minimal infrastructure
knowledge required within this we're
excited to announce two new capabilities
model co-hosting that allows you to
share underlying resources across models
for cost optimization and custom
prediction routines which allows users
to include pre and post processing
python code alongside your model binary
to simplify your architecture and then
in the middle we're also excited to
introduce an optimized tensorflow
runtime only available on vertex this
leverages model pre-compilation and
smart op placement across gpus and CPUs
to drive big improvements in throughput
and latency early benchmarks show huge
improvements up to 8 and 6X for
throughput and latency for tabular data
and material Improvement for based
natural language models and finally
deploying models for serving is only
half the battle vertex provides model
monitoring and explainable capabilities
to ensure your models stay healthy or
are retrained and redeployed as they
erode
next AI infrastructure isn't just about
training and serving machine learning
models managing features and embeddings
to feed into your ml models is
non-trivial as organizations scale both
the number of models and the usage of
complex unstructured data as part of
these models feature stores and Vector
databases can become a challenge to
implement to support this newer AI
infrastructure need vertex AI offers a
fully managed feature store and matching
engine and today we're actually excited
to announce support for streaming
ingestion across both these Services
where you can now have new features and
embeddings synchronized and updated in
real time to improve the accuracy and
timeliness of predictions and both these
Services support a wide variety of use
cases ranging from recommendations
engines search engines image
classification add targeting and much
more
and finally we don't want to stop at
just providing hardware and management
infrastructure we want to provide a path
to adopting Leading Edge Solutions
coming from research and partners that
can drive true business value through AI
first we have tabnet now available
through vertex ai's tabular workflows
this makes it easier to build accurate
and explainable models on billion scale
data sets with built-in interpretability
on vertex the tabnet pipeline
automatically selects the appropriate
feature Transformations search space
based on the input data data size
prediction type and your training budget
we'll hear a little bit more from Kai
about Uber's early experience with
tabnet second we have an alpha fold
batch entrance Pipeline and vertex AI
this allows biotech companies to embed
Alpha fold into their own workflows to
predict protein structures at scale with
optimal architecture
and third we have a solution from our
partner Nvidia called Merlin Merlin is
an end-to-end framework to design and
deploy custom large-scale recommender
systems we've partnered with Nvidia to
build a reference solution Deployable on
vertex Ai and gpus and gcp which
includes data processing model training
and model inference
next we'll jump into some great examples
of Enterprise teams leveraging some of
these Technologies and let's go ahead
and start with Kai from Uber
thank you so much Michael hi my name is
Kai I'm the product manager for Wilbur's
internal entry and virtual learning
platform called Michelangelo
Michelangelo Powers 100 of Uber's most
business security commissioner use cases
such as rice ETA eats ETD driver Rider
matching and is home field
recommendations allowing our machine
learning developers that we were to
focus on what they are good at building
and deploying models without worrying
about the underlying infra complexities
our strategy of building Mark Angel is
based on actively evaluating and
integrating industry-leading third-party
components while selectively investing
in key platform areas to building house
so we architecture Mark angel in a
modularized way so that we can easily
integrate third-party tools and
components near plug and play fashion
when we explore the solutions for
large-scale model architecture search
and training we found the vertex Ai
automl and tablet
in the past year we'll be working
closely with the vertex AI team to
evaluate the performance of of automl
and tablets with Uber's real-life use
cases and data the evaluation results
met the POC success criteria in terms of
model accuracy training efficiency
compatibility with Michelangelo Tech
stack so we've decided to integrate both
tools with Michelangelo and made them
available to All Machine learning teams
at Uber on the other hand along the way
to meet Uber's extensive and complex
machine learning needs we've made
multiple feature requests and product
Improvement suggestions to vertex AI
team which in turn improves automl and
tablets
one example use case is Uber is prep
time model which is used to estimate how
long it takes a restaurant to prepare
the food after water is received this is
one of the most critical models at Uber
with the highest QPS query per second we
compare the tablet results with the
Baseline model and the tablet
demonstrated a big lift in terms of the
model performance
overall the POC results are promising
and we are excited to continue closely
working with the gcp team to drive
production adoption within Uber with
that I passed down to Joanna to talk
about their use cases at kohir
thank you Kai
hey everyone I'm Joanna Franco here I'm
very excited to present how cohere is
accelerating large language model
development with Google Cloud queer's
mission is to unlock NLP capabilities
enabled by large language models and
make them accessible to all developers
with just an API call
to achieve this cohere abstracts the way
the heavy lifting from the end user
including collecting and creating a
large Corpus of high quality data
training a pre-trained learning models
and post fine tuning optimizations for
low latency inference in a highly
reliable environment
here we outline coherence achievements
in building a scalable training
evaluation and inference stack taken as
a whole this technical stack as a key
competitive Advantage which has enabled
cohere to rapidly scale our models while
ensuring quality responsiveness and
safety of our end products all of which
is implemented in Google Cloud platform
with that I'll pass it on to set
hey I'm Seth I'm a machine learning
engineer at cohere I'll give a high
level overview of oh heels training
framework so go here has a proprietary
training framework called fax it uses
Jax and Cloud TPU v-force to train large
language models
TPU V4 pods are some of the most
powerful AI supercomputers in the world
a full V4 pod has 4096 chips and the
diagram on the right you see a few
topologies of slices from the full V4
pod that are available on the Google
Cloud platform and that can be used by
facts to train these large language
models
again kohio uses facts to train our
Baseline models as well as custom models
that are trained on customer data sets
using the fine tuning feature on the
cohere platform
Fox's job is to consume billions of
tokens and train models as small as
hundreds of millions to as large as
hundreds of billions of parameters
coming to some concrete benchmarks in
the middle we see pipeline parallelism
which was the old way of training large
language models that go here
with facts the scaling and the plot is
represented by tensor parallelism so for
a fixed number of tokens the tensor
parallelism method of training large
language model scales much better
and on the right we see that with using
512 V4 cores the maximum model size we
can schedule is 340 billion parameters
and at a minimum batch size the step
time is 6.21 seconds
this enables us to train large language
models very fast and bring those
improvements to customers right away
thanks for having us uh Mikhail
ambassador of the year
great yeah great to hear those stories
from both Uber and Co here really
pushing the boundaries of AI and really
leveraging the AI infrastructure
services on gcp I also wanted to end
this with actually two quick stories
from two other customers first is with
credit karma for those not familiar
Credit Karma is a multinational personal
finance company that continues to
innovate to provide more personalized
products and services they have a
mission to make Financial progress
possible to everyone one of their use
cases is to better recommend Financial
content and financial offers for their
members their approach was to generate
embeddings from Financial content and
mix those with features from offers
based on user cohorts to improve their
input features for their recommendation
system the diagram on the bottom left
gives you a quick system overview of how
this architecture works we have
Financial content on the left where they
used a pre-trained sentence encoder
model to extract embeddings on the right
they also bring in features from
Financial offers they bring both these
different domains into vertex's feature
store that are then leveraged for
training and serving their
recommendation engine and this really
had two benefits highlighted on the
right side with a few of their quotes
one is really for the internal Credit
Karma machine learning platform team
shout out to debashy's das who's been
working with us
um his team can Now launch richer and
faster features up to 3x faster and
second is of course the user experience
the consumer customer experience and
using a b testing they've seen
significant increase in content
engagement and offer conversion
next we have a customer Arbor bio
leveraging deepmind's Alpha fold
Solution on vertex AI Arbor bio is a
biotech company based in Massachusetts
discovering and developing the next
generation of genetic medicine our bio
is really developing extensive toolbox
of proprietary Gene editors using both
High throughput data screening as well
as Ai and why do they really look at
Google cloud and gcp number one they
really look to augment their toolkit and
processes with deepmind's Alpha fold
model and they really wanted to inject
the capability to predict structures of
proprietary protein sequences in a
scalable robust and cost-effective way
now Arbor bios data driven and AI based
approach really has a lot of high
variability of Hardware needs across
CPUs and gpus and this was a great use
case for gcp and vertex ai's managed
infrastructure and really the impact you
can see with the quote in the bottom
right is that autobio scientists are
able to increase their productivity and
generate actionable insights in hours
instead of months so let's go ahead and
and end with a summary
um you know to summarize we truly
believe that to drive the most value
from ai ai infrastructure now needs to
be at the core of your AI strategy we
cover three pillars of AI infra on gcp
flexible and scalable Hardware manage
infrastructure on vertex AI an
accessible state-of-the-art AI Solutions
and you can see we can continue to
invest heavily in each of these with
lots of new capabilities and launches
rolling out and finally again we're
super thankful for our customers and
partners leveraging these Services
providing us feedback to continue to
improve these and sharing their stories
with the broader industry so we can all
learn from each other so thank you so
much for joining us today please enjoy
the rest of Google Cloud next and have a
great day foreign